I was chasing him the poor soul who saw
me he was wearing a thick red winter
coat and glasses climbing up the side of
the mountain with a sharp little tool if
I had known he was coming I would have
run of course I would have run but it
was already too late the second he saw
me saw my horrible
ugly face it was already over I felt all
those familiar feelings Bubble Up I knew
as well as I knew anything in my life
that I would need to kill him my name
well I don't know my name not really I
think I had one once a long long time
ago I don't think I always look like
this like this big ugly monster but who
can say those memories were blown away
like a snow drift life this life at
least has never been easy for me I don't
like hurting people but at least up
there in the mountains people didn't see
me that often how could I know strange
men who would come for me how could I
possibly know that it was all going to
get so much worse the poor man in the
red coat who saw me tried his best to
run I think my crying frightened him I I
wish my mouth could make words if I
could I would have told him how sorry I
was but it didn't matter anymore I kept
moving towards him like I was being
pulled Along by some invisible leash in
his Direction I tried to stop I tried to
think really hard and to focus I kept
telling myself no not this time you're
better than this you can let this one go
before the sentence is even fully formed
in my mind I'm already there I'm already
on top of him I looked down and see his
terrified face tears Frozen on his
cheeks eyes wide with horror you can't
even begin to describe if you haven't
seen my face he was still looking at me
but hurt that he was still looking at me
I leaned in and opened my mouth wide
enough to swallow him whole soon enough
there was nothing left of the man in the
red coat and I was alone again all I
could think to do was sit there on the
freezing Mountainside and weep why did I
keep doing this why couldn't I stop
myself I asked myself these questions
again and again but I never got an
answer it felt like I knew myself a
little less every single day sometime
later I don't know how many days weeks
or months two huge black noisy creatures
came towards me out of the sky the
second I saw them I turned and started
moving away I couldn't let those
creatures see me I knew something
terrible would happen if they did it was
best to just move away let them leave me
alone nobody had to die what I didn't
know was that I was the reason they were
there the two flying black creatures
landed on the mountain behind me and
groups of people climbed out carrying
strange objects I didn't recognize I
huddled Myself Away in a corner it's one
of the men came
I was so afraid I couldn't stop myself
from crying I didn't have the words I
couldn't tell them how much danger they
were in couldn't tell them that I didn't
want to hurt them that they should just
leave me here but it was it was already
too late one of the strange men walked
right in front of me and saw my face he
said Jesus this thing is one ugly I
started screaming I couldn't help myself
my head started going fuzzy and my heart
hurt the man who'd seen my face was
already backing away knowing that just a
few seconds too late that he'd made an
awful mistake it wouldn't save him now
nothing could save him I tried to stop
myself but find hurt it just made me
scream louder I turned and lunged at him
but that made things worse now so many
of the others had seen my face too with
fat wet tears rolling down my cheeks I
knew that I would have to destroy them
all even though I didn't want to but
this time they fought back
suddenly heard all these horrible loud
noises all around me and felt white hot
pain all over my body they were shooting
at me both with the objects they held
and other even larger weapons attached
to their strange flying vehicles this
made my confusion and anger even worse I
went berserk jumping at them and
attacking them with my claws and teeth
they may have been able to hurt me more
than ordinary people they were just as
easy to destroy as anyone not that it
made me feel any less terrible for doing
it even though they did attack me first
who were these strange aggressive people
and why have they come here to attack me
soon enough I destroyed all the ones who
had seen my face there was nothing left
to do but just sit there and weep again
I felt so terrible about everything I'd
done to them it was a pain deep deep my
chest but then suddenly everything went
black and a sack was pulled over my head
I couldn't see who did it and I'm glad I
didn't more importantly they didn't see
me I think after that they bundled me
onto one of their flying vehicles and
took me away I had no idea where I'd end
up next all I could do was stand there
with a bag over my head and cry still
blinded and after a long period of
flying through the air I was pulled out
of the vehicle and dragged away
somewhere I feel grateful that I didn't
know if I was here to be punished it was
probably what I deserved soon enough I
was brought into a room where a bunch of
strangers were looking at me I later
learned that one of these strangers was
called Dr Dan and Dr Dan seemed very
interested in what had happened back on
the mountain the one who put the bag
over my head was talking to Dr Dan he
said that thing killed all my men tore
through them like tissue paper our Heavy
Artillery barely slowed it down and it
regenerated any damage it sustained
almost immediately
fascinating Dr Dan said yet it seems so
docile now why what activated its rage
State during the confrontation Connors
looked at its face that's when it went
ballistic hearing the story told again I
started to weep it was true everything
they were saying was true I killed all
those poor people even though I I
couldn't help it there was no place for
me in this world if all I could do was
hurt people and be better off not
existing at all everything was a bit of
a blur after that the next time the bag
was removed I was in some kind of room a
perfect Cube that clanked and clunked
every time I moved around in it no
windows no doors probably for the best
all I could do was pace around this
little Cube and wait wait until Dr Dan
was ready to conduct more of his tests I
never felt more empty and alone but at
least I couldn't hurt anyone here thank
heavens for small mercies sometime later
I was packed again and taken out of the
cube I don't know where they took me but
suddenly I felt that terrible Feeling
Again knowing that someone out there had
seen my awful ugly face knowing that no
matter what I really wanted to do I had
to destroy them it was the only way but
how they'd seen my face while I was
wearing the bag it didn't make sense
none of it made any sense I felt the
strong tug of the invisible leash again
pulling me towards the one who'd seen me
I screamed and roared and wailed and
tore off the bag I started Galloping
across the land in front of me all
Barren and empty until I reached the
water I was right next to the ocean I
leaped in and started diving heading
deeper deeper deeper eventually I found
a strange metal sphere somehow I knew
just the one who had seen my face was
somewhere in there I tore it open and
found him a man in an orange jumpsuit he
screamed his water filled his lungs
moments later he was
swim back to shore tears dissolving in
the ocean where the strange man bagged
me again and I was back in the cube it
was a moment of calm soon things were
going to get so much worse a terrible
day it happened a lot like last time the
time next to the ocean I was inside my
cube when I felt that terrible feeling
the sensation of being looked at this
time I I somehow sensed that the one who
saw me was even further away I said to
myself this time I'd resist I'd stop
myself nobody would be hurt but
resisting the pull hurt me even more all
I could do was wait in Hell In terrible
pain as I heard people panicking and
scrambling outside the walls of my room
soon enough it was too late I couldn't
stop myself I needed to find the one who
saw me and Destroy them the walls gave
way like wet sand as I tore through them
there were so many people in white coats
standing around the room a terrible
smelling gas that burned my throat
flooded
killing most of the people around me but
as always I survived and I started
running feeling the pull towards the
person who saw my face I busted through
walls and galloped across the ground
feeling else took by each second I could
hear the distant hum of more of those
flying vehicles in the air behind me but
it didn't matter none of it mattered all
that mattered was finding the one who
saw me and wiping them off the face of
the Earth no matter how awful it made me
feel inside soon I arrived at a town
where everyone was gathered in the
center they all turned and looked at me
and I could feel the rage rising to a
fever pitch there were so many of them
all those poor people and not long after
more people with guns arrived wearing
strange goggles they all looked at my
face too I couldn't help it I'm so sorry
I just couldn't help it I try not to
think about how many people I killed
that day but soon enough a bag was
placed back over my head and I was
dragged back to my room which they'd
rebuilt while I was gone I remained in
there for a long time just weeping
consumed by my own seemingly endless
sadness and until one day some time
later I was dragged out of my room and
taken to another chamber I could hear
something that wasn't human breathing
when they pulled the bag off my head I
was standing across from a monster
staring right at my face a huge terrible
reptile with a thick hide and giant
Claws and teeth it hissed when it saw me
it was happening again the pain started
I was weeping and wailing was this all
my life would ever be a mix of silence
and violence only existing to hurt
others and be sad hurt and alone unable
to even control my own actions what kind
of life is that if you can even call it
a life the monster hissed and said you
are disgusting
silently I agreed now go check out
scp-096 the Shy Guy and scp-096 versus
scp-343 for more tragic tales of the shy
guy